das sind bilder gefühle erlebnisse die
man einfach nicht so löschen kann
und ich möchte behaupten der behauptet
dass er das einfach löschen kann das in
der angst vor sich selber hat
also dann
du wirst ja sanitäter 2010 weil das
upgrade dabei am 24 juli jährt sich zum
zehnten mal wenn du so dass da kommt 70
die gedanken die den kopf schwirren
es ist jetzt wo es daraufhin geht schon
mal so dass mal wieder ein bild mehr
oder weniger erscheint was so in der
spontanen erinnerung kommt teilweise
waren zum autofahren dass ich mich
plötzlich an ein bild erinnere abends
vom fernsehen dass ich nicht mehr dem
fernseher erfolge sondern hier und da
mal noch mal bilder durch den kopf gehen
und ja ich einfach nochmal drüber
nachdenke war das alles so richtig was
ich getan habe aber ich bin noch nie zum
ergebnis gekommen dass irgendwas
verkehrt war und diese gedanken kommen
die immer mal wieder egal in welcher
situation oder vermehrt ist das immer
speziell jetzt im juli an den
jahrestagen und das ist kann ich es noch
gar nicht so genau beantworten will da
kommen so immer wieder mal aber soweit
ich es bis jetzt von psychologen
einsatznachsorge teams gehört habe ist
das ganz normal wichtig dass man diese
bilder wieder loslassen kann und mein
gefühl ist es dass ich die sehr gut
wieder loslassen kann aber sie nicht
verdrängen
und ich glaube dass das doch hilft damit
umzugehen und nicht sei es in trauer in
angst oder sonst irgendwas weiter zu
leben weil von beruf bin ich mal
zwischen notfallsanitäter und
berufsfeuerwehrmann und da muss ich
funktionieren wenn ich im dienst bin und
du weißt ja auch nicht alleine da die
weiß dass ein paar kollegen sagen aus
und ist heute immer noch aus oder
vielleicht auch so hinterbliebenen oder
zu opfern in kontakt kollegen austausch
findet da ich jetzt bald gesagt
regelmäßig statt
dadurch dass wir damals jahr als
ehrenamtliche einsatzkräfte da waren wir
aus unseren gesamten kreisverband
zusammengezogen waren ist es natürlich
wenn man sich trifft bei verschiedenen
veranstaltungen ist ja über das man auch
an diese erinnerung nochmal anknüpft wie
geht's dir wie geht es dir danach aber
seitdem hat sich irgendwas geändert
und ja dadurch bin ich also kann ich
will ich auch gar nicht mit dem thema
endgültig abschließen konnte wie geht es
dir antwortete also ich würde lügen wenn
ich sage es belastet mich überhaupt
nicht aber es ist auch nicht so dass ich
sage ich brauche hilfe
also ich komme für mein empfinden ganz
gut damit klar zumal ich auch natürlich
von seitens der hilfsorganisation hilfe
bekommen habe danach gesprächsangebote
bis hin zu der möglichkeit
psychologische hilfe einzuholen und
dergleichen
also da sind wir bei uns im kreisverband
auch sehr gut unterstützt worden
nach dem ereignis und das
notfallsanitäter da erlebt man ja
sowieso eine menge kriegt viel mit wie
viel leid
man hört immer so machen sie wie einen
privaten beruf trennen
ich kann auch jemand der seine väter ist
also ein bisschen abspielt geht es bei
einem erlebnis schrägstrich einsatz in
der größenordnung meiner persönlichen
meinung nach geht es nicht und ich denke
da werden mir oder ich hoffe dass mir
alle einsatzkräfte von
hilfsorganisationen als doch feuerwehren
nicht widersprechen dass das ein
erlebnis ist was man nicht von jetzt auf
gleich abstellen kann als daher einfach
nicht nur um eine immens hohe zahl an
verletzten geht sondern um in dem fall
leider auch verstorbene den wir nicht
mehr helfen konnten und das sind bilder
gefühle erlebnisse die man einfach nicht
so löschen kann
und ich möchte behaupten der behauptet
dass er das einfach löschen kann dass
der angst vor sich selber hat also wir
sind sozusagen die lakers sind da
allerdings auch sein
ja auf jeden fall die hat braucht mich
gravierend verändert also seitdem also
ich hab mich insofern verändert als ich
seitdem wesentlich ruhiger an
einsatzstellen wenn weil ich weiß dass
sind da an nervosität und hektik das
schlimmste ist was einem passieren kann
weil ich da erlebt aber das mit
gezielten handeln und kurzen
überlegungen sehr viel bewegt werden
kann und in die wege geleitet werden
kann
das ist oftmals drei worte sind die
reichen um eine riesen maschinerie in
bewegung zu setzen und glaube dass das
meine kollegen im rettungsdienst
bestätigen können dass es schwer ist
mich inzwischen aus der ruhe zu bringen
seitdem dann immer noch mal zurück an
den tag wie jetzt erlebt
juli es war ein schöner heisser tag
so fing alles an wir hatten eigentlich
die hoffen dass wir es irgendwie
schaffen mal so nah ran zu kommen dass
wir auch was davon erleben weil wir zwei
jahre zuvor in dortmund ja nur der
bahnhofs posten waren und gar nichts von
der nach schwert an sich erlebt hatten
dadurch dass wir in duisburg halt an der
letzten vereins vereinsanlage vor der
veranstaltungsfläche waren haben wir
neben fall tatsächlich die hoffnung dass
wir zumindest mal im blick oder
irgendwas
geräuschkulisse erhaschen können was sie
aber relativ schnell herausstellte dass
wir davon nichts erleben werden weil es
einfach zu laut war zu viele menschen
waren und leide die entfernung doch noch
zu groß war
und irgendwann am nachmittag richten wir
mit dass von seiten der vereinzelung
anlage einen hilferuf gaben also
mitarbeiter kam zur disposition
polizisten lang hat er mit gibt's halt
da unten liegen zwar liegt einer da
müsst ihr euch mal darum kümmern weil
wir an der reihe waren ist meint rupp
dar eingeschickt worden
und wir haben im bereich zwischen glaube
es war der autobahntunnel und im
nächsten tunnel haben wir einen
bürgersteig sitzend gefunden der sagt
ihm würde nicht mehr gut gehen
und als das soweit geplant war und
rückmeldung gegeben war dass wir ihnen
zur in verriet stelle bringen wurde uns
auf einmal noch einer neben die tragen
wir sie jetzt hier die müsst ihr auch
mitnehmen waren die worte von dem in
dance hingesetzt hat im ersten moment
ein bisschen irritation aber gut wir
sind profis wir machen weiter den kurs
ebenfalls in augenschein genommen und
gefragt was passiert ist oder seit ihr
kreislauf geht nicht mehr kann nicht
mehr und habe dann noch einen weiteren
truppen gefordert
zur unterstützung dass er den auch raus
tragen kann weil er war offensichtlich
auch nicht mehr alleine gehfähig und als
ich wieder in den zu meinen inzwischen
zwei trupps zurückkam konnte ich
erkennen dass aus dem bereich des nächst
größeren tunnels leute raus kamen die
von oben bis unten voll staub fahren und
das auf einmal ein riesen geschreibe
hilferufe und ich kann mich noch an die
worte erinnern die ich da schon vorab
das sterben menschen im ersten moment
war ich doch erschrocken und sehr
irritiert mein erster gedanke war hat da
gerade ein attentat gegeben weil für
mich sagen die im ersten moment so aus
als hätte
da womöglich eine explosion gegeben im
ersten eindruck daraufhin sind wir
weitergegangen
und als wir an der rampe ankam sah ich
links die man am boden liegen in der
rampe an der wand vor uns und mir wurde
von einem mädel karl glaube ich war es
in die hand gedrückt hier der ist
kollabiert der brauchen zugang
aber was wie im ersten moment irritiert
hat sie stellte sich als freiwillige
feuerwehr unter brandmeisterin vor und
intensiv schwester woraufhin ich hier
gesagt habe du betreibst du jetzt
erstmal wir können jetzt erstmal gar
nichts machen wir sind noch in der
gründungsphase
das hatte sie auch direkt verstanden man
hat sich um ihn gekümmert
daraufhin wurde noch eine außentür
ausgetragen und ebenfalls in die rampe
gelegt wo der blick direkt sagte da
musst du jetzt sofort hin und beim
ersten tag stellte ich sofort fest dass
der reanimation pflichtig ist habe dem
ersthelfer kurz angewiesen was er zu
machen hat habe ihm vielleicht zwei
sekunden drei sekunden über die schulter
geschaut haben dann gesagt ich lasse
dich jetzt alleine
du machst das richtig mache so weiter
und bin zu dem anderen gegangen bei dem
ich ebenfalls feststellen konnte dass
der animationshit ist allerdings da
schon laienhelfer am reanimieren waren
und auch die machten es augenscheinlich
richtig wo finde ich wieder manchmal
eindruck zugewandt habe und dem gesagt
habe dass der alle die als leicht
verletzt anzusehen sind auf dem
bürgersteig sortieren soll dass die die
laufen können erstmal weg können dass
wir platz kriegen und die ersten wir
waren von unserer seite her noch die
ersten im nachhinein
sich gehen weiter meter weiter zur
erkundung und habe bei der ergründung
nachhinein festgestellt dass bereits von
der veranstaltungsfläche her ein oder
zwei tage trips ebenfalls angefangen
haben zu sortieren zu sichten und auch
schon reanimationen angeleitet haben und
wie gesagt in meiner weiteren erkundung
habe ich dann festgestellt dass im
tunnel selber im nächsten zu großen
ampel selber 23 reanimation lagen und im
bereich der großen rampe nochmal müssten
21 gewesen sein zu dem zeitpunkt hatte
dann noch mal drei trupps die zur
unterstützung geschickt worden sind
die habe ich auch das ist mir im
nachhinein angekreidet wurden erstmal
dazu verwendet um die verletzten und
betroffenen zu sortieren und von der
straße in die straße freizuhalten und
frei zu schaffen habe parallel über
unsere einsatzabschnitt leitung
sogenannte patiententransport züge
angefordert nicht um irgendwelche
patienten abzutransportieren sondern um
die personen die sie eine unter
reanimation befinden adäquat weiter zu
versorgen
über den weiteren abtransport habe ich
mir zu dem zeitpunkt tatsächlich noch
gar keine gedanken gemacht weil ist auch
in dem moment gar nicht meine aufgabe
weil ich erst mal nur für das für die
ersten maßnahmen wichtig war und das hat
muss im nachhinein sagen
zu meiner verwunderung perfekt
funktioniert aber weil den von
vornherein klar wie es überhaupt sind
verletzungen kam
nein überhaupt nicht der hinter der
hintergedanke oder die erste gedanke
explosion war zu dem zeitpunkt noch
nicht gelöscht
der bestand in meinem tiefsten inneren
immer noch ich habe wo sie ehrlich
gestehen nicht bewusst danach aus
ausschau gehalten ob es irgendwo spuren
davon gibt aber naja also wirklich
erfahren was passiert ist habe ich erst
am nächsten tag für mich ging zu nehmen
moment tatsächlich darum die eigene
sicherheit nicht zu vernachlässigen aber
erstmal darum alles mögliche zu tun um
zu retten was noch zu retten ist
und da ist keine offensichtlichen
verletzungsmuster in die richtungen gab
und keine beschädigungen an
infrastruktur den bereichen ab wie
gesagt war es nur noch ein hintergedanke
keine präsenter gedanke mehr und wirst
du sagen willst erstaunt wie gut das
funktioniert hat wie ist es also dass
klicke jetzt zu hause stehen erst ein
bisschen komisch kennen ja auch nur die
fotos die sie drängen und plötzlich
funktion funktioniert glaubst du das hat
doch dieser notfall situation zu tun
oder das ist einfach hat mit sicherheit
ein bisschen mit zu tun
das hat aber gerade im bereich des
tunnels wie viele menschen auf der
straße waren sehr viel damit zu tun dass
meine teams oder meine trupps die mir in
dem moment unterstellt waren
das gemacht haben was sie sollten
nämlich die straße frei gemacht haben
die ganzen leichtverletzten betroffenen
auf den gehweg und die gehfähigen aus
dem tunnel raus geschickt haben so
schnell und so weit wie möglich dass von
der düsseldorfer straße also sprich
westseite muss das gewesen sein
die patiententransporte bis fast in den
ereignis raum rhein fahren konnten dass
die wirklich sofort aus dem auto raus
und anfangen konnten also sofort in die
lage reihen konnten und anfangen konnten
zu arbeiten wie lange hat es das alles
abgespielt
kann ich ehrlich nicht drauf antworten
gefühlt drei stunden vier stunden fünf
stunden aber in der realität war es
wahrscheinlich ein viertel der zeit nur
ich habe das zeitgefühl wie ich mich
ziemlich er komplett verloren in dem
moment weil es einfach nur noch der
automatismus abarbeiten der lage ist
damit das bestmögliche ergebnis dabei
rauskommt und seit dem tag dennoch nach
hause fahre ja wir sind von
einsatzkräften aus unserem kreisgebiet
abgeholt worden
wir haben vor ort nichts mehr selber
abgebaut das haben alles andere nach
alarmierte kräfte für uns übernommen
wir sind gesammelt in einer großen
unterkunft wie wir also als wir wieder
heimatgebiet ankamen einer großen
unterkunft gesammelt wurden haben da
erst die möglichkeiten zu gesprächen mit
einsatznachsorge team gehabt und dann
noch mal mit essen trinken kaffee was
man wollte versorgt worden
haben uns dumm ich noch mal drei stunden
zeit dafür genommen
die ersten eindrücke miteinander zu
verarbeiten mit denen die dafür
ausgebildet sind zusammen und hatten zu
dem zeitpunkt schon die ersten wenn sie
mal termine möglichkeiten für die
nächsten tage genannt gekriegt für
diejenigen die sofort bedarf haben die
möchten dass wir da gespräche führen uns
hilfe holen können
was denkt man da an so einem tag kann
man dann abends noch zum einsatz
bradley ich glaube ich habe in der nacht
gar nichts mehr gedacht weil das
körperlich doch anstrengend war
ich glaube es ist von der geistigen
geistigen anstrengungen streng mit einem
klausur marathon zu vergleichen
die ich weiß nicht was ist wahr eine
stunde anderthalb zwei ich weiß es nicht
ich jetzt tatsächlich waren bürger dazu
seine vita sind anderen notfällen
erfahrung wie sie sagen das zweite dann
auch das was das ereignis so anders
gemacht hat oder sind es verschiedene es
sind irgendwo zwei paar schuhe glaube
ich also ich vergleiche ist nicht so
direkt mit meinem arbeitsleben als
rettungsdienstler weil wir da im
gewissen maße doch immer auf die
situation irgendwie vorbereitet sind
die wir vorfinden das ist ganz selten
mal dass wir da eine situation kommen wo
ganz was anderes ist wie das was wir
erwarten bei sonne sanitätsdienst bei
einer großveranstaltung kann das alles
erwartet
es werden alle die so was bis jetzt
erlebt haben sagen es ist ein
schreckmoment dem man aber ganz schnell
verarbeitet weil man helfen will
und ja in dem moment auch als derjenige
da steht der helfen muss gab dann auch
vielleicht im moment der hilflosigkeit
noch mal als elfter platz ist nicht mehr
helfen kann so viel in dem moment nicht
und von der leitende von verschiedenen
masse und menge an einsetzen dass wir
zwar sie kann ich alle versorgen konnten
oder waren ja dass ich weiß was du
meinst das gefühl hatte ich tatsächlich
nicht
ich habe im vorfeld in meiner
ehrenamtlichen ausbildung für den
massenanfall von verletzten im vorfeld
viele übungen mitmachen dürfen und auch
an einige naja vielleicht übertrieben
großen übungen teilnehmen dürfen
die im rahmen von
wie steht es bei gesagt globalen
ereignissen aber von terrorakten und
dergleichen stattgefunden haben und da
habe ich recht früh gelernt schnell zu
entscheiden ja nein vielleicht und diese
entscheidung auch auf den patienten
umzulegen
so sagen ja der hat ne chance nein keine
chance naja vielleicht wir schauen wir
noch hilfskräfte da sind aber dann noch
machen ob wir dann noch versorgen können
das ist ja jetzt alles genau trainers
triage system es ist jetzt alles ein
bisschen salopp dargestellt aber ist
einmal im endeffekt sind es die
entscheidung die da getroffen werden
müssen und man der blüten dass ich in so
eine situation gebracht wird
nein weil am ende gemischte ich habe
schon selber ausgesucht
ich habe selber gesagt ja ich möchte mit
fun zu dem einsatz und im nachhinein
es ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen
stolz dass man helfen konnte dass ich
behaupte mal federführend mit
entschieden haben wir entschieden habe
oder dazu beigetragen habe dass es nur
in anführungsstrichen 21 tote gegeben
hat die wir mal ein bisschen weiter weg
dann von dem tag
du hast sie selbst gesagt das ist ein
ereignis damit kann man nicht
abschließen auf der trauerfeier hast du
auch ein jahr später gesprochen und von
bildern also das gesagt
die ausbilder gesehen wie man sein leben
lang nicht vergessen wird
wie sehr begleitet dich sozusagen das
erlebte und in der zeit danach den
früheren folge ja also das erste
halbjahr nach eigenes habe ich noch
täglich mehrfach bilder in erinnerung
gehabt und bilder durch sortiert abläufe
vom einsatz noch mal durchgegangen und
immer wieder mich selbst kritisch
hinterfragt war das alles richtig war
das richtig die verletzten erst mal nur
dahin zu sortieren
war das richtig die laienhelfer bei den
reanimationen zu lassen wäre es nicht
besser gewesen die eigenen helfer dahin
aber im ergebnis bin ich immer wieder zu
dem ergebnis mit zu dem ergebnis
gekommen dass es so eigentlich richtig
war weil eine reanimation kann auch ein
laienhelfer durchführen aber ein
patienten oder einen verletzten adäquat
zu bewerten und zu sagen na ja der
bleibt jetzt besser hier oder der kann
weitergehen
das sollte schon jemand machen der
zumindest eine rettungsdienstliche
grundausbildung hat und mit dem ergebnis
bin ich immer wieder mit mir einig
geworden also ist so richtig war
du hast doch gesagt du hast ja auch
hilfe in anspruch genommen wie das
konkret aus große gesprächsgruppe wo
jeder sein erlebnis erzählen konnte kann
wenn er möchte wenn ich wollte konnte
einfach nur dasitzen arbeitsgruppen dass
man irgendetwas gemeinsam getan hat oder
sich gemeinsam bestimmten themen
gewidmet hat und die gemeinsam
bearbeitet hat oder dass man nachher
gemeinsam
die gedenkfeier herstellt hat wie sie
ablaufen soll
was gemacht werden soll und dergleichen
ist sie doch mal durch die nicht
erkennen gelernt habe bin ich mit in die
gebeten wurden sie zu dieser gruppe zu
begleiten wenn sie dann nicht alleine
hingehen wollte und ich habe da relativ
lange für mich und für die
notfallseelsorger vorgehalten die
informationen dass ich dabei war als
rettungsdienstler und also ist auch die
vorbereitung von dem ganzen hingegen
kamen immer mehr freie kritische fragen
auf in richtung ob der rettungsdienste
alles richtig gemacht hat und warum man
das so gemacht hat oder nicht anders und
ja das system hinterfragt bundes weil es
doch für außenstehende offensichtlich
nicht alles ganz klar war wie es da
abgelaufen ist warum es so abläuft ja
all solche fragen kamen da auf und nach
rückfrage oder rücksprache mit den
notfallseelsorgern habe ich mich
entschieden alle darüber zu informieren
wer ich bin wieso ich da bin
und ja also es mit meinem dabei sein auf
sich hat und es wurde erstmal kritisch
beäugt was ich gar keinem übel nehmen
ganz im gegenteil dadurch dass ich da
gespräche mit bekommen dann kann ich das
auch vollkommen verstehen dass ich erst
mal kritisch bewertet worden bin
was ich aber ich hoffe bei allen
ausräumen konnte durch teilweise lange
persönliche gespräche und ja einfach die
informationen die fragen beantwortung zu
den sachen die sie nicht verstehen
konnten
weil sie das system großschaden zeigen
ist einfach nicht kennen weil sie wie so
viele andere auch einfach nichts damit
zu tun haben in ihrem alltäglichen leben
und hat zu dem zeitpunkt hatte man schon
entschieden dass auf jeden fall ein nach
vom rettungsdienst von den
hilfsorganisationen sprechen soll
und in der nächsten gesprächsrunde wo
man so die themen und das
organisatorische zusammengetragen oder
zusammentragen wollte ist relativ
schnell in der gruppe der einstimmige
beschluss gefallen dass ich derjenige
sein soll
der da reden soll weil sie halt einfach
na ja in gewissem maße zu mir schon
vertrauen gefasst hatten und auf dem weg
kam es dann dazu dass ich da reden
sollte ich weiß nicht mehr mit vielen
aktionen und an dem ich beteiligt
rettungskräfte arbeiten an rücken
bemerkten am anfang das war im wettlauf
um die zeit
das sind viele bilder nicht vergessen
werden also wird hier bestimmt auch
mitbekommen wie jetzt im mai da würde
sie auch der prozess dann beendet das
heißt es wird keinen schuldigen geben 21
tote 56 100 verletzte was hast du da
gedacht also davon gesagt hat im ersten
moment habe ich mir ein bisschen mehr
arbeit weil normal sagt man ja wenn eine
veranstaltung gemacht wird wenn es
irgendwo eine häusliche feier gibt und
geburtstag gibt es gibt immer ein der
ihn veranstaltet der für das was
organisiert worden ist
die verantwortung trägt so ist es ich
glaube in jedem fußballverein
es ist schon ein bisschen die frage
gestellt wieso ist weil sie noch
veranstaltung in der größe kein meer
oder vielmehr keine verantwortlichen
gibt und ich glaube nur wenn tatsächlich
eine persönliche verantwortung tragen
muss nachhinein das dann wirklich alle
konzepte noch genauer hinterfragt werden
weil wenn irgendeiner wenn ich die
verantwortung für irgendetwas tragen
muss schaue ich selber glaube ich
dreimal er vier mal genau hin was was
wir machen wie wir's machen wo wir es
machen und ob der mögliche gefahren
bestehen oder entstehen könnten
weil ich glaube ich könnte nicht auf
dauer mit dem hintergrund leben
schuld am tod von anderen menschen zu
sein was er jetzt auch gesagt bei
zukünftigen veranstaltung würde sie so
etwas wünsche niemand der die gut auf
raten dass man auch im zweifel jemanden
hat er dafür geradestehen muss wie
siehst du denn großveranstaltung sonst
so viel upgrade
ich glaube solche events vielleicht
verändert verändert
direkt verändert nicht im rettungsdienst
der sanitätsdienst taktischen vielleicht
ein bisschen vielleicht so mehr wir ein
bisschen wir haben bei veranstaltungen
im nachhinein eigentlich immer noch eine
schippe draufgelegt zu dem was gefordert
war
weil wir halt einfach die erfahrung
gesammelt haben was wenn es passiert ist
gebraucht wird also es gibt da rechnungs
schlüssel für art der veranstaltung an
dessen man dann hochrechnen kann wieviel
einsatzkräfte man benötigt und in der
vergangenheit hat man sich annähernd
daran orientiert so dass es immer gut
gepasst hat und seitdem liegt er immer
noch mal zwei sanitätskräfte mehr drauf
oder zusätzlich noch ein rettungswagen
auch wenn er nicht gefordert war als
medizinisches personal bzw
komponente an der veranstaltungs stelle
du weißt ja danach sehe ich auch öfter
noch bei veranstaltungen und einsatz
wie geht man daran hat man das in meinem
hinterkopf ich glaube das darf man auch
nicht kann man nennt bei jedem einsatz
im hinterkopf haben wenn man sich sonst
damit selber nur unnötig nervös macht
klar man vergisst es nicht es wird auch
bei den zukünftigen einsätzen mit
sicherheit hier und da mal kurz
auftauchen wie gesagt bis jetzt
behindert mich nicht ich hoffe dass das
auch weiter so bleibt hat aber keine
auswirkung darauf dass ich jetzt mit
angst nervosität oder sonst irgendwas in
den einsatz war von einer
großveranstaltung gehe
nach duisburg die loveparade geschichte
gewesen
jetzt kann dabei doktormutter unter
anderem namen adele dass die ursprungs
loveparade in berlin auf 27 gründet und
er plant jetzt eine neue recht unter
anderem nahmen unter anderen motto
wie findest du das und da ich selber
tatsächlich ungarn hat zur loveparade
gefahren wäre als gast als besucher
ursprünglich nach berlin
das aber irgendwie organisatorisch
zeitlich nie hingekriegt habe ich will
nicht sagen ich würde mich freuen wenn
das noch mal versucht aber ich
persönlich kann auch nichts finden was
dagegen spricht weil es da jetzt einmal
zu einem ereignis gekommen ist was sehr
tragisch war will ich gar nicht außer
frage stellen er jetzt auch eine
mehrjährige pause gemacht hat wenn es
mit einem neuen vernünftigen
sicherheitskonzept gestartet wird warum
nicht was man bedenken muss ist passt
der ort passt das konzept passt die
besucheranzahl dahin
ich denke wenn das alles kritischer
betrachtet wird als bis dato um sollte
er das tun
im umkehrschluss
spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen
[Musik]